a federal judge is pushed back court
appearances for Laurie Lachlan and
Felicity Huffman the actresses both
charging the College Admission scandal
will now appear in a Boston Court on
April 3rd and one of Laughlin's old
interviews has come back to haunt her
when I had children always thought I
don't want to do anything that one day
might rear its ugly head and my children
have to pay the price for that I'm just
as scared as you
Lachlan who played Aunt Becky on full
house is currently free on 1 million
dollars bond
she discussed morality with the
Christian Broadcasting Network the
morals are right there's a message to at
every in every episode you know how to
be a good person how to be a better
person
right from wrong it's a good message
Lachlan and Hoffman may be the most
famous faces caught up in the scandal
but you might also recognize this woman
I'm Jane Buckingham trend strategist the
50 year old parenting expert and author
appeared multiple times on GMA and she
hosted an ABC Family reality show
[Music]
Buckingham is accused of paying fifty
thousand dollars for an a CT Proctor to
take the test for her son
meanwhile Ben Stiller who brought his
daughter on Ellen today poked fun at the
admission scandal she's here because
you're looking at college we are
visiting colleges this week Wow
yes exciting Southern California
colleges uh-huh and how's that going
it's great she is gonna go to Yale on a
full football scholarship I mean look
there's crazy pressure that the kids go
through and the parents go through but
you know obviously you've got to draw
the line exactly
[Music]
[Applause]